with this latest piece of information
the investigation into andreas lubit's
motives took a darker turn
the german prosecutor said the german
wing's co-pilot's suicidal tendencies
date back to a time before he became a
pilot
he had at that time
been in treatment of a psychotherapist
because of what is documented
as being suicidal
in the french alps workers continue to
search for the flight recorder
in the hope it will offer clues about
the last minutes of the flight
the device contains electronic
components which record
all the flight parameters this is very
important for the ongoing investigation
investigators fear that this important
second black box may have been damaged
on impact
it doesn't seem to be emitting any
signal until now the crash site has only
been accessible by helicopter
or on foot french authorities are
opening up vehicle routes
we're finishing a temporary road so
recovery workers can use four wheel
drives
but we're also working on ways to give
normal vehicles access
the priority is on bringing out all
human remains
forensic teams working in a mobile lab
have so far identified dna strands of
over half the 150 crash victims